you
[Music]
good morning welcome to the session on
integrity of AI my name is Sean and
rest' a researcher here at Microsoft
Research and I'm very excited to
introduce to you three different talks
in this session that all center around
this very difficult problem of creating
real and end intelligence systems that
can operate in the open world that can
leverage in coordinates speech language
dialogue planning learning and sort of
tie it all together so you know
technology has made a lot of progress
recently in these individual wedges but
it is still incredibly difficult to sort
of tie these things together and
actually make a real system so I'm sure
many of you have run into so today we're
going to hear talks that introduce some
recent advances in this and recent
systems that are integrative the time
multiple components together we're going
to learn about some core challenges how
to do troubleshooting and blame
assignment and then at the end we're
going to learn about some tools and
platforms that can actually make this
all possible so our first speaker is
Louis Philippe Morin see Louis Philippe
is a assistant professor assistant
professor in the language technology
Institute at Carnegie Mellon he also
leads the multimodal communication and
machine learning laboratory and today
he's going to talk about core challenges
in multimodal integrative AI systems
focusing on machine learning and
particularly deep learning so please
join me in welcoming LP thank you thank
you everyone my name Willie Philip
became in the US LP too long for this I
will be talking about multimodal machine
learning or if it was a longer title or
more catch it will be probably deep
learning from Mertz model system it's an
exciting time to be working on AI given
all the advances that happen on these
integrative a
system virtual human robot holler land
and some of the living room or
ubiquitous computing and so I've got
lucky enough to early in my career
working on one of these projects 43
people working together a lot of them
are in this room and the one thing you
learn about this is the challenge of
integration and so I will present one of
this which you may have seen some of you
but let me introduce le one of these
system hi I'm Ellie thanks for coming in
today I was created to talk to people in
a safe and secure environment I'm not a
therapist but I'm here to learn about
people and would love to learn about you
I'll ask a few questions to get us
started and please feel free to tell me
anything your answers are totally
confidential are you okay with this
yes so how are you doing today I'm doing
well that's good where are you from
originally I'm from Los Angeles oh I'm
from LA myself great one of the core
challenges when you build this
technology is to understand and interact
communicate with human so how do human
communicate the three v of communication
verbal every time you choose to speak
you often decide on specific words the
with the words or the phrasing is
important the pragmatics is even more
important traumatic means word in the
context of a social interaction but
there's also the second v vocal every
word sometimes I call it the 50 shades
of yeah and I saw that in fact from my
previous postdoc Stefan 50 shades of
year because every word yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah each of them has a slightly
different meaning and so that's really
important for computer to understand
and since my background was in computer
vision I'd put the biggest business on
the third V visual gestures arm gesture
but one of the important thing the first
that I often look is gaze
you also have facial expression facial
expression is important not just the
basic emotion but all these emotion like
confusion and surprise as well so this
is the challenge one of the big
challenge when we build integrative AI
is how do you have how can we create
computers to recognize communicative
Jews and so the challenge that I will
talk about today is how do we integrate
verbal visual and vocal information to
infer something about the user something
about their emotion their social cues or
if they're in a clinical setting
something about maybe depression anxiety
or PTSD this is something that has been
studied a lot there is a lot of really
interesting work on multimodal
multimodal by the way started if you
look only on in the 1970s a really
interesting works if someone knows about
the McGuirk effect
McGirt effect okay so this is a
wonderful effect that if you use the
same audio track exactly fuh fuh-fuh and
change the visual track shows a
different mouth shape human here bah bah
bah simply by the change of the void of
the visual and I excited everybody in
multimodal
and this is one of the aspect that
started all the work on audio-visual
emotion it was usual speech recognition
and this computational era came with a
lot of interesting work and multimedia
and also in psychology there was the
landmark word with Debbie's McNeal on
language and gesture but suddenly in
2000 we started looking at interaction
human interaction and what happened in
2010 is definitely the deep learning era
today I will emphasize on that last
piece
this because this is probably what most
of you are here to talk about is deep
learning how can we not talk about deep
learning but I want to tell you that
there's been a lot of work on multimodal
from which this work is building upon
when we look at the multimodal machine
learning these mersa model machine
learning taking this verbal vocal and
visual and fusing them together there
are five challenges that are important
in these case the first one is
representation alignment fusion
translation and Co learning I'm talking
about them and I will give you more
details in a second this is if you have
a chance this is a full survey on this
topic there's more than 253 reference
but a more important thing is if you are
to study a field like multimodal
you need a taxonomy what I saw that we
can interact together and talk about the
same thing and that's what I will
introduce first in the first part of
this talk and then I will talk give you
real world example of recent progress on
this topic so the first one is probably
one of the most interesting and most
interesting one is representation how
can we learn to represent and summarize
multimodal data in a way that explored
complementarity and redundancy the first
kind of approach if you look at the
literature these days and probably the
first one you thought about when we
think about representation is joint
representation Gorge representation
means that you're bringing together the
work the data from one model to another
bringing them jointly together and let
me show this visually what will a joint
representation for human communication
looks like it is a representation where
if I say the word I like it or if you
see my joyful a smiley face or you hear
the joyful tone you would like these
three very different behave
to all come to a similar place in that
joint representation
similarly for more anger or some tent
voice you would like this or even for
surprise you would like to learn this
joint representation and this sounded
for me like science fiction but
thankfully there's really smart people
who push on this and this is in fact
there is a possibility that this is
possible and that came from the work
early work in the 2009-2010 looking at
the joint representation there's some
early work back in Stanford really great
work from Roslin but here's the one
example that really blew my mind and it
is doing vector arithmetic in that field
in that space and what do I mean by this
and what is what we do i learners a
joint space where images can be
represented and word can be represented
in that space and what would we do we'll
do everything I take my image I encode
it and then I take the words blue and I
subtracted the word the image I take the
word red I added and then I take the
riza the solute the the coding and then
I start sampling from there and what do
you start getting when you sample red
cars in the same way you can do with
yellow cars or you can do with day and
night this was really for me i opening
this was a moment where you see there is
a way of bringing language and vision
together and these were separate field
for a long time i was probably one of
the few and 2008 that went both to ACL
and cvpr at the same time I'm quite sure
of that because they were overlapping in
time exactly at the same week so but now
these days we see a lot more researchers
doing between the two but this is
Georges representation but if you ask me
where I believe this line of research is
doing now is coordinated representation
coordinated
presentation does not force to have this
one joint space but says hey I will have
a space for my language representation I
have a space for my visual
representation but I will coordinate
between them what does this coordination
means it has different flavor but one of
them is the recent work here at the
University of Washington and PTI on deep
CCA is a great example of coordinated
what is the challenge when you learn
independently language representation
and visual representation one of the
challenges if I ask you the first
dimension of my language representation
how does it relate to my first dimension
of visual representation if you learn
them separately there's no there is no
coordination the CCA allows you to
coordinate the dimension of that
representation it does it in such a way
that the first dimension will be the one
where there's the most correlation with
your data most correlation you with your
data does not mean the exact same thing
it just means that we have the you find
the bases the space bases of the space
axis where the coordinate where the
correlation is the highest and then you
repeat it over for every dimension in
such a way that they are orthogonal to
each other this is a great example I
believe to have space that are
coordinated but at the same time that
they are separate but coordinated at the
same time this is the first challenge
representation the second challenge is
alignment I have all of this data and I
want to identify the direct relations
between elements from two or more
modalities what does it mean one of the
example is explicit alignment and
there's some really great work early on
with sri and carlos and others who are
doing alignments where you want to align
one modality explicitly with another
modality where you are one align your
gestures with your language or your
verbal with your voice at the same time
or there's an
type of alignment which is implicit
alignment an implicit alignment is the
most popular these days most popular
these days because what it is is you
have a task in mind maybe a fusion or
you have a translation in mind but as an
intermediate state as an intermediate
step you will do this latent process of
alignment so it's an intermediate but
the objective function does not have
alignment directly so here's an example
of implicit alignment I give you this
task of doing image captioning you have
an image and you want to learn the
caption internally in your mind you've
done implicit alignment you realize that
the dog is related to this object that
the tennis ball is part of this the
murky water is the rest of the image
you've done that implicitly as part of
the task and now these days there's
beautiful algorithms doing some of it
for us
one of them all so beautifully named
attention model attention model is an
example of a process where I want to
predict from an image try to predict my
caption but as I'm doing this I will
decide where we made sure that looked at
and I do this over and over in such a
way so that eventually when I create the
caption a woman is throwing a frisbee in
part you can see the attention moving
over time so this is an example of
implicit alignment this is the second
core challenge the core challenge is
what everybody thought of multimodal
before fusion fusion is the task to join
information from two more modality to
perform a prediction task and a
performer prediction task is the most
important we are closer to the objective
function representation you're closer to
the input at that point so the most
well-known approach for multimodal are
early and late fusion early you
concatenate you input and then always
you have
agnostic Lee a model that learns the
prediction tasks or late fusion where
you explicitly do the tasks in one
modality and then the other and then
have a fusion later on in later stage
but this is the order way to look at
fusion now these days there's a lot more
work on deep learning doing fusion the
problem and the problem in the solution
with deep learning is that the boundary
between representation and fusion in a
deep network architecture is often
really fuzzy where is it that I'm doing
this classification task and where is it
then during your presentation is a gray
zone but there are approaches like
kernel based approaches that are clearly
fusion based approach multi kernel
learning is an example where each
modality will have its own kernel its
own similarity metric and then that will
help for diffusion or graphical models I
know why are you still talking about
graphical model I strongly believe in
graphical model I believe that is is a
great way a true when it comes down to
diffusion or is time to bringing the
predictions past that's often where in
the place the graphical model will shine
this is the third challenge fusion the
fourth one is translation the process to
obtain geing data from one model to
another where the translation
relationship can often be open-ended or
subjective and there are two types of
these that's part of the taxonomy one is
XAML base where you have example and you
use it as part of your model another
name for this will be non parametric and
parametric that would be another way to
look at it where you're learning this
but your model in itself has this data
as part of the model where in a
parametric approach you will learn a
model that I approximate your data and
then use it during the translation and I
will take this from a great friend Stacy
marsala which collaborated with
stephhencher on this where this is a
translation problem there's
folks here who worked on this problem
where I will take only the transcript
and the audio of a movie and
automatically generate the visual
gesture so everything you will see there
are the visual gesture that are
automatically generated work on this
early work on that with the beat system
from justin castle is another great
example so let's see this all in real
time oh that was a really short one okay
it's naughty little bastard Your Honor
I'd like to ask for a recess I'd like an
answer the question judge the court will
wait for an answer if lieutenant
Kendrick gave an order that Santiago
wasn't to be touched
why did he have to be transferred
lieutenant Kendrick order the Code Red
to me because that's what you told me
kind of Kendrick to do oh yeah what is
what bad you'll cut these guys loose
Your Honor if you're more go to Tran
Your Honor you doctored the logbook can
turn yourself into Jim
Colonel jessep give you martyr to Cobra
you don't have to answer that question
I'll answer the question you want
answers I think I'm entitled you want
the truth you can't handle the truth and
one of the biggest challenge in
translation what is it well it will be
its evaluation how do you evaluate a
good translation and people in machine
translation those that is a big
challenge
yeah and it is also challenging when you
translate between modalities that's one
of the big challenge and the last one is
co-learning this is the transfer of
knowledge between modality including the
representation and predictive model the
idea is I have a task in one modality
and I will be using another modality to
help the task in the first modality the
core learning can be happening when you
do have parallel data where you have
parallel data where you exactly the same
instance in both modality or more
challenging is the weekly supervised
approach where you have data but the
there the supervision between it is more
at the group level or at the cluster
level and often you have the hybrid
version of that so this is a summary I
mean if you have too much time and you
really want to fall asleep really
quickly there's a survey paper of 24
pages that gives you the full taxonomy
of multimodal machine learning this is
available on archive at this point I
wanted to give you this first summary
before giving you three example concrete
recent progress in multimodal machine
learning making it more concrete and
hopefully tools that you can use in your
own research as you're building inks
aggressive AI system one is about
representation the second is about
alignment and the third one is about
fusion but the first one is probably the
most important looking at representation
I have this verbal vocal and visual data
and represented as a text image and
audio and I would like to predict
sentiment why do I pick sentiment
anybody in NLP knows in fact they're
probably tired of hearing about
sentiment but there is work on
multimodal sentiment that is done
through a video and in this case if I
learn them joint representation then my
internal representation hm is the direct
function of each of my representation
from the text image and audio this inter
Airy theory is great if you have
infinite amount of data don't worry
learn from that but in many case we
don't have infinite amount of data and
you want to learn but also put
interesting knowledge into it let's look
at sentiment as an example
sentiment is has three type of
interaction unimodal bimodal and tri
model the unimodal interaction is the
following you have a unimodal cube this
movie is sick it is still ambiguous it
could be sick and a now I'm adding the
mental models at the surface for
meetings to do it without the multimodal
but this move
is fair or a smile these are cues that
will show positive this is ambiguous how
strongly positive but it is in itself a
cue and loud whoops oh it comes out a
mess really loud I'm loud that's I've
been told but doesn't mean I'm always
positive or always negative
loud dozen is an ambiguous one this
movie is sick and then I have also a
smile then or from this is the bimodal
interaction this is resolving the
ambiguity that I presented previously
had but if I say this movie is sick and
I say it loudly you still ambiguous in
what it is but trimodal interaction are
really interesting because this movie is
sick with the same nonverbal will be
really strong well this movie is fair
which is a really strong verbal cue will
in fact does not change the interaction
so when we build representation we need
to take into consideration the unimodal
bimodal and trimodal interaction this is
why we instead of doing a simple joint
representation we will learn what's
called a sensor fusion network a sensor
fusion network look like a really simple
equation until these are really
important these one are really important
why are they important because they are
the one who will automatically create
for you the unimodal representation and
the bimodal representation and since
we're in a world where everything is 3-d
or 4d let's make a 3d version of that
can extend it to three modalities and
the three modality has the unimodal
representation in green the bimodal
representation and the tri model so you
have a representation that explicitly
encode trimodal interaction bimodal
interaction and unimodal interaction
making it easier for the model to learn
and that's what we see an experiment on
many different topic but this one is for
moon similar
sentiment analysis by using this
representation you get an improvement of
a state-of-the-art very significant and
as a good teacher you are a professor
you always go back to your student and
say hey is it really that if you need
all of them
or is it just one modality that's much
stronger and yes you need all three
bimodal unimodal electron model to get
the improvement the second example I
wanted to talk about is temporal
attention I'm talking I'm talking a lot
not everything I say is important now
everything I say is important so as a
human we're really good at attentive
some cues some evidence we pick and a
lot of things within your we're really
good at this as you become more senior
faculty I learned that you even better
at selecting like that doing aha at the
right time yes so how can we have
computers also learn what is important
temporarily we suggested this new
algorithm which is an extension of
existing approach where as you get the
input observation over time you will
have a layer that looks at what is
important what is important in this
video
take this and learn some salient z-score
and then eventually take this
information in a recurrent attention
gate unit this your attention gate is
really interesting it's a simple one but
powerful one taking the hidden
representation that I previously had it
will do two things
it will decide based on the inverse of
the attention so if I say hey this
segment don't attend to it what does it
mean it means bypass bypass completely
and forget that this ever happened
but the opposite is true if the
attention here is really strong then I
want to take into consideration that
observation that's a simple gate but
that is simple get that improved
performance because automatically by
using that you can automatically realize
which part of a video
so is really important when you do
classification this is for event
classification in this case where you
realize which field or which image are
the most important for the tasks that I
have in mind and eventually you will see
the field again in a second the last one
I want to talk about is multi modal
sequence of video so if I sure if I do a
sequence modeling with lsdm this is easy
we do it we've done it it works
wonderfully on language but for multi
modal what would be their way to do it
the multi modal way is to simply do a
some kind of early fusion where I just
add the other modality in my lsdm but we
want to do it in the multi modal way
where information between modalities is
coupled what do I mean by coupling I
mean that we will create a multi view
lsdm what's in the middle to view lsdm
the multi-view lsdm takes as input like
a normal LS theum the previous season
space and the observation at time T but
the magic here comes at the first stage
where you look at what's important at
what I just observed and do it in such a
way that I keep a multiple memory cell
and here's something that I find really
important you remember how I told you
joint representation do it but be
careful maybe coordinated is better the
same true for NFC M if you put
everything in the same memory cell then
you force your algorithm to do all the
hard work for you so instead of that we
will have three memory cell one for each
modality and then we will do the same as
if input forget and output gate but each
of them will be multi-view most of you
is where the important aspect word
happen because there's different
topology and that's really cool
so let's play with it what can we do
with these different topology because
what do we have as input of this module
so if I want to know four modality one
how do I represent modality one I
definitely take the input from modality
one and then I have the hidden state for
modality one but I also have the hidden
side from the other modality so you can
do is have two different design
parameters alpha and beta that tells you
how much do I trust my current view and
how much do I trust that I trust other
views and then you can start playing
with things you can say I only trust my
current view that's a view specific oh I
only trust the other views when it comes
down to remember the temporal oh I want
to do fully connected but the more
interesting is the hybrid where you look
at a different weighting of the
different modalities so this is a quick
version the hybrid works really well on
the children engagement because it takes
into consideration the interaction
between language gesture and voice and
learned that into a temporal aspect so I
appreciate your attention the take-home
message that I want to give you the five
core challenges in multimodal machine
learning representation alignment Fusion
translation and Co learning if you're
really interested please look at the
survey and I wanted also to give you
three examples where you look at
representation temporal attention and
multi-view lsdm thank you very much
attention okay question please speak
your question into the microphone we
have a micron err right here
great talk whoo so there's kind of an
implicit assumption when you're
presenting that the different modalities
are reliable but some cases the meaning
arises from a misalignment between the
modalities in a sense of sarcasm would
say something positive in a negative way
or you know when I'm asking my anger
with a smile that conveys very different
meaning than if they're all the
modalities are aligned so I'm just
curious to what extent you have looked
at or people have looked at where the
meaning arises from the disconnect
that's really interesting
so the I will say there's more work to
be done there
the part of the the previous work that
look at this problem is the people who
look at implicit alignment so I have a
task which is looking at sarcasm and as
I do this task I will model the
misalignment implicitly a latent
variable but the part that is important
in your case is I need to do this
implicit alignment condition on my task
and a lot of the current work they will
do the alignment more as a way to erase
this misalignment and ignoring it where
in your case you want to condition that
misalignment to the task you have in
mind so that you take that into
consideration and have not seen as much
work that condition is there a lot of
work that will try to forget about the
misalignment or mission translation is
an example where this misalignment you
in fact just want to handle it but not
take advantage of it but I think this is
something that should be done there's
some work in that direction but is more
to be done yet
yeah okay I'll repeat my question so you
gave us beautiful examples of how you
are using deep learning for solving a
number of multi model problems my
question is where it doesn't work do you
think is going to fix all of your
problems in multimodal systems or this
is good for a particular set of problems
and you're going to needing other
approaches or hybrids or other things
yeah so and this is a very important
question I don't know if your schweiz
here no okay if I had but as you want to
get different answers from different
researchers I will share my insight I
think of human communication and not I
think but a lot of work could be on
human communication look at it as a loop
so perception reasoning and action this
is a really simplistic and I think that
deep learning is very good in the first
part of perception very as long as you
can get objective reliable labels for
your objects that you see for the words
you hear it does very good at this when
it comes with uncertainty it does not
always handle uncertainty as well other
frameworks Bayesian frameworks for
example handle uncertainty in a better
manner so you can imagine then when you
get into the reasoning this is where you
need to be able to handle uncertainty
and because data is always limited in
these cases you probably also want to
think about it from reasoning but you
want to be able to handle with limited
amount of data so I think this is where
at this point you will see other
approaches happening and that's where
you start seeing some interesting work
when you come down to the action the
same thing happens if it is a clear
action that you want to generate you
start seeing interesting you work on
generating a flower just from there the
problem there is open-ended that's a
problem that deep learning has a lot of
problem in that is when the problem is
open-ended how do you handle all the
different
version and how to evaluate that but for
perception I think this is great
reasoning we'll need some help and when
it comes to generation I deep learning
probably can't handle it but we need to
handle how to evaluate it and we need
new objective function to know how to
evaluate that yeah thank you okay and
our second speaker in this session is
Dez Marunouchi VESA is the newest member
of the adaptive system and interactions
group at MSR she just finished her PhD
at ETH Zurich and I think this is week
three of her position here at Microsoft
Research so she is diving in headfirst
her research is at the intersection of
machine intelligence and human crowd
intelligence and today she's going to
tell us a little bit about how to
troubleshoot these systems go ahead back
up
oh yeah it's tricky okay yeah so I'll
talk about our work on troubleshooting
integrity of machine learning systems
and this is joint work together with
Ajay Kumar Eric Horvath and Donald
Cosman so um we are these days living
and working in exciting times and we are
seeing many applications of AI being
developed and applied in many problems
not only in academia but also in
industry and only in the last few years
we have seen multiple cases of
successful AI applications in
transportation or personal assistance or
gaming and problem solving now this is
indeed very impressive and a great
motivation for all of us however despite
the recent developments in the last few
years we have also seen a couple of
events where the deployment of AI
systems
in the real world has caused unpleasant
events for the end users for instance
this is the case of a Google captioning
app which Ted is human is a gorilla
another example is the case of Tay the
Twitter bot that started making socially
unpleasant conversations on the web in
less than 24 hours and I guess the
bottom line for both these examples and
I guess for many more examples is that
intelligence systems are still fail and
when they fail the outcome may actually
be disturbing for the end users and it
may cause the end users to lose trust in
these systems and this is the reason why
we focus our work on troubleshooting
machine learning systems so that system
designers can understand their systems
better and can they can take multiple
approaches in order to make them better
and this of course goes in the same line
of thought of the concerns that Barbara
raised this morning on her keynote that
once you understand the mistakes of your
system better and once you know more
about the error that the systems make
you can be able to improve the system in
the future so I am not sure why this is
automatic as well did you solve that
yeah okay well so in particular we
focused in troubleshooting integrated
machine learning systems or in other
words machine learning systems that are
composed of components that our machine
learned these components communicate
with each other they exchange data input
and output are among each other and of
course they provide a single output to
the end user and since these systems are
not yet perfect and they sometimes make
mistakes there might be multiple ways on
how to apply fixes on each of the
components and this fixes may be on
expensive now the challenge that we are
aiming to solve in this world is the
four
given the multiple possible fixes for
each of the components in an integrative
system and the limited development time
from the sides of the system designers
and engineers we would like to know or
to give this information to the system
designers where should they invest the
development effort in order to have the
biggest impact now of course there have
been there has been previous work on
troubleshooting however most of the work
has been focused in troubleshooting
physical devices or devices that have
this Hardware component they do not have
any uncertainty in the output data and
the physical components are clearly
separate from each other now when we
started working on integrative machine
learning systems and troubleshooting we
realized that troubleshooting machine
learning systems presents many new
challenges to face mostly because the
output of machine learning components
has a lot of inherent uncertainty in the
output data which then creates complex
interactions in the system architecture
so I'm going to illustrate what I mean
by this by using our main case study in
this work on our main case study was an
image captioning system which takes an
image as an input and it generates a
textual description for this image and
this is a system that is running in the
real world it was also developed at
Microsoft Research in 2015 it has three
machine learning components the first
one is a visual detector it sees the
image and it generates a set of words as
an output that are associated with a
certain confidence score now the second
component which is the language model it
takes this as an input the list of words
and it generates a set of sentences that
are plausible and could serve as final
captions for this image
and finally the caption of the ranker
sees the image again it computes
similarity scores between the textual
descriptions generated by the language
model and the image and it outputs one
sentence as the final best caption and
in this case it is a man flying through
the air on a snowboard now let us have a
look from this system where the image
captioning system has generated the
wrong output for this image the system
output is detection a blender sitting on
top of a cake and let us see what is the
data that flows within are the
components and how how can we analyze
this data and what is going wrong here
now if we go back to the visual detector
we can see that the list of words that
was generated by the visual detector has
the word blender in there which is wrong
but however it has a very low confidence
score with respect to the other words
like steady key or cake or bear then the
language model has generated a set of
sentences the final best the final best
caption that was selected by the real
anchor is in this list and it has also a
low or likelihood in terms of how
suitable is this in in terms of language
and finally the caption or anchor has
many other eternities but however it has
chosen this one as the final our best
caption now in this case which of the
components would you blame or would you
fix in order to solve the problem would
you blame the visual detector because it
has detected around words although with
a very low confidence score would you
blame the language model because it has
generated a sentence that does not make
sense or would you blame the caption of
your anchor because among all the other
choices that is head from the language
model it has selected this one as as the
best one now as you can see the problem
is challenging here and the interactions
are are complex and the first thing that
we did when we started working on this
was to actually characterize the problem
of troubleshooting for the case of
integrity of machine learning systems
and we saw that this system has
remain characteristics that make the
problem particularly challenging now
the first characteristic is that machine
learning models and components they are
usually have continuous quality measures
which means that their system state is
not binary and our question here is in
this quality continuum where every
component is partially failing but also
partially succeeding in performing its
task how can we quantify the effects of
each components quality into the final
system quality second are many of these
systems because of bad architectural
design or because of reusability and so
on they may exhibit a complex component
entanglement which means that the
responsibilities between the components
they might be entangled and blur the
boundaries between the components might
be blurred and our question here is how
do we disentangle are the effects of
component failures on the overall system
and finally what we have seen with
working with such systems is that
actually improving one of the components
does not necessarily guarantee you the
improvement of the final system and what
we want to do with our methodology is to
actually detect such cases of non
monotonic error propagation where
improving one of the components may
deteriorate the quality of the final
system so um based on this problem
characterization we developed a human
assistive troubleshooting methodology
where we introduce people in the system
execution here are people investigate on
the output of each machine learning
component via using a predefined crowd
sourcing tasks so what they actually do
is that they check the output of the
machine learning component they check
whether there is an error in this output
and they take this output and after that
we are able to reintegrate the the fixed
output of the components back into the
system execution
so as you can see people here serve as a
mechanism for generating simulated
improved states of the components so
that the system designer can see whether
this improved state can actually make
the system better and which of the
components actually is going to make the
system better and notice that the human
intervention at this step is actually
crucial to the problem of
troubleshooting because only in this way
we are able to simulate this improved
states of the component and be able to
to integrate them back into the system
without making significant development
efforts so we collect all these traces
about the system execution the way how
the system has failed the fixes that
have been applied on on the failures and
how the system evaluation has changed
after that and this provides a rich set
of data that is available to the
designers so except that in our
methodology we can also execute a set of
fixes in a single workflow so a workflow
is a set of fixes that has been applied
one after the other in the sink in a
single system execution for example in
this case we will be able to apply the
fixes from the first component and then
only after these fixes have been applied
we apply other fixes on the third one
and so after applying a joint a joint
work so execution this system designers
can see what is the joint impact of one
or more fixes or one or more components
at the same time so what can one expect
from such a troubleshooting methodology
with respect to the problem
characterization well first of all you
could detect non-monotonic error by
introducing fixes in one of the
components and measuring the system
quality before and after the fix and
checking whether this impact is actually
positive or not another way how you
could use this methodology is to
quantify the component impact by
applying individual and eyes only
fixes on the components and then
checking whether are you can find any
component that has where you should
invest the most significant development
effort and finally if the system
designer suspects that two components
are for example entangled and wants to
test this he or she could implement
individual fixes in for example the
first two components and then apply a
joint fix and make the proper
measurements afterwards um so let's go
back to our case study and see how we
apply this methodology in the image
captioning system um for this system we
developed a customized crowdsourcing
task force of the machine learning
component for example for the visual
detector we asked people from the list
of words to see whether they could add
or remove objects that should be
mentioned in the caption or whether they
could add or remove activities from the
base for the language model component we
asked people to flag and report
sentences that were generated by the
language model but they probably had a
bad English or they did not make sense
in the real world and finally for the
cut of caption your ear anchor we asked
people to check the top 10 best
sentences generated by the caption
rerender and to tell us whether there
was actually a better sentence in this
set that could have made it as the best
caption and are what we see by
collecting this data is a set of
statistics and information that we all
could provide to the system designer
this is an example of applying a visual
detection see here the word kite is
wrong and after people could remove this
with the crowdsourcing test and
introduce the word umbrella then the
caption becomes from a blue and yellow
guy to a blue umbrella in a field of
flowers and of course of the data that
we collected is it's rich and it has a
lot of information here
going to show a summary of the results
that we had in the y-axis I show the
percentage of cases where the caption
that was generated by the system was
considered as satisfactory from the
crowdsourcing workers and we can see
that from the evaluation of the system
only in 57 point 8 percent of the cases
the caption was considered as
satisfactory
which also give you gives you an idea of
how the quality of the system is at the
moment and how far can we go by applying
individual fixes in each of the
components we can quantify their impacts
for example in this case we can see that
the caption read rank of fixes are
actually the most promising one and by
applying all the fixes one after the
other in a single workflow we can
estimate an improvement upper bound on
the system in understanding how well
could we do if we were able to implement
all the proposed fixes in in the system
and finally differently from what system
designers thought on at the beginning of
this study the fixes that were applied
to the visual detector were not the most
promising ones and they were actually
manifesting non-monotonic
error propagation due to complex
component entanglement here is one
example from our studies which showed
non monotonic error propagation the
original caption of this image was a
teddy bear sitting on top of a computer
and here we can see that the word
computer is in the list people could
remove this word from the list and they
could also improve the confidence scores
because now they were sure that these
words are actually in the image and they
should be mentioned in the caption and
the caption after applying the 6 becomes
a person wearing glasses and holding a
teddy bear sitting on top of a keyboard
which is obviously worse than the
original output now when we went back to
debug and see what was actually going
wrong
um what happened is that the language
model has statistically injected the
word person into the sentence because it
had a higher beliefs on people wearing
glasses rather than teddy bears wearing
glasses which is the reason why the word
person appears there and why the
non-monotonic error propagation happens
and this is what we were able to detect
via our methodology so um so far mostly
talked about individual fixes in each of
the components however there are many
alternative use cases for this type of
methodology uh one could for example the
component prototyping say you have
envisioned this system which needs to
make use of a certain component however
this component is too expensive to
develop at the moment or probably
impossible with the current tool and you
could try to prototype this via the
human input and see how well with your
system do is it has such a component um
another idea would be to experiment with
architectural changes so so far we have
been focused mostly on applying fixes
that strictly follow the system
architecture that was given to us by the
by the designers however one could for
example see whether or stating one of
the components in two may give you not
only a better modular design but also a
better quality and finally since there
is usually I mean almost mostly often a
gap between the fixes that one could
generate with crowdsourcing and humans
and the fix is that system developers
can implement it would also be
interesting to actually introduce noise
in the human fixes or for example
partially apply them so that you could
see how well would your system do even
if you apply imperfect fixes into the
into the component for example for the
visual detector we tested a hundred
percent improvement on on the
opponent however we do not know maybe it
is not possible to have like the perfect
component deck but we want to see what
if we improve it on the by 60% how well
could we do here um so to conclude I'd
like to spend the last few minutes on a
few takeaway points that we got from
this word and and where we are heading
to
so obviously one very clear takeaway
point here is that our job does not end
with system development and initial
engineering complex systems that will
solve complex tasks they will need
continuous monitoring evaluation
improvements but also adoptions to new
domains that are yet to come
and in order to do so we need
generalizable frameworks that can expand
over a set of systems on not only a
single system now it is also interesting
to think about what are the kind of
tools that these frameworks need need to
provide so far we have been thinking
about machine learning as a machinery
that conforms label data into models
into predictions and maybe even
decisions now it is of course clear that
together with these decisions will also
get mistakes or decisions with
unreliable confidence or strong biases
that are included in the model or non
ethical output or barely transparent our
decision-making now as we integrate
these models into whole systems all
these issues that I just mentioned on
biases and ethical issues we can get
interleaved together in the same way
that in the same way that mistakes can
get propagated into a system
architecture so in our work we say the
errors in a system architecture they can
get propagated suppress or transferred
from one component to the other but one
could say the same thing about biases
and ethical issues and one could also
argue that these problems are equally
important to the
and untroubled shoot now in our work we
found the human input and intervention
as valuable not only for generating
supervision data but also for making
more fine-grain interventions in in
understanding errors and at this point
it is also important to think it's one
we want to integrate people into
troubleshooting these frameworks we need
to think about different roles that
people are can have in such frameworks
like not only as crowdsourcing workers
but also as end users and system
designers for instance in a
crowdsourcing our perspective in order
to have good frameworks we need to have
usable tasks but also clear user
interfaces and training for the workers
from an end users perspective such
frameworks should provide the
possibility for end-users to collaborate
with the system to give feedback to the
system but also adapt the system
according to their needs for instance a
user could adjust the system by giving
new training personal data or to make
the system better but also maybe by also
flag flagging mistakes and
mispredictions and giving on giving this
kind of feedbacks and finally from a
system designers perspective such
frameworks could have better
visualization and domain analysis tools
in order to understand a better and
deeper the system for instance for the
image captioning app that we have
considered so far we want to understand
what are the different types of errors
that the system makes and what different
types of fixes are more applicable to
all two different errors and as a final
point I would like to say that side by
side with troubleshooting integrity
testing tools are also as important for
for this framework people have done a
lot in software engineering for having
good testing tools and one could also
think about what can we reuse from these
frameworks but also what needs to be
adjusted for software that relies on
artificial intelligence
yeah so these are all ideas that are
worth exploring in the future and I'm
also eager to learn more from people in
this room on what are their real-world
problems when they actually deploy these
applications in in real settings and I'm
excited to learn about the size and work
that goes into this class yes thank you
[Applause]
hi thanks the computational linguists
used to say that the reason you need
grammar was so you could say things that
are surprising you know the great white
shark was eaten by the baby or the the
final Jeopardy failure where it did
Toronto is a u.s. city is just
statistically there and I'm wondering
which types of errors that you're going
after are sort of amenable to tuning the
system and that versus which ones are
sort of a flavor of a failure mode of
the nature of how you think about
generating captions and whether you met
you worry about that distinction or how
you how you think about that there are
errors that you should go after and
errors that maybe you should not go
after so this the error that you should
go after also depend on the domain where
this system is supposed to work
on this system when it was first built
the main motivation was to generate
captions for people that have visual
challenges and the perfect caption would
be the caption that generates well
descriptive sentence for for the users
and this is also the way how we test it
and we try to troubleshoot the system so
we wanted to have descriptive captions
that has enough information now of
course if you will readjust the systems
with
different domain that needs to
understand different things or for
example needs to output funny captions
or creative captions or artistic ones
then of course you need to tell this to
the end users that are doing the
evaluation and to to provide the
evaluation criteria but but it is also
true that the evaluation criteria has to
readjust with the new domain and maybe
also the fixes have to be readjusted to
the new domain
in the last part I mentioned dealing
with ethics and things like that do you
think the your approach will scale to
these issues because to me it sounds
like a you know involves more difficult
problems like like can you define
physical or non ethical outputs like
objectively you know maybe you can
resort to crowdsourcing but you know the
criteria may may be different from
people to people present a person or you
know and also you cannot decompose the
definition of ethical into functional
components at least now so I don't know
how you can you know track down the sort
of the sort of problem I suspect that
the problem with biases and ethics has
more entanglements that than the usual
errors so it might be difficult to track
down from which component it comes from
however what we have seen from the image
captioning system is that there are
cases when you can actually track this
down
we had these examples of a little girl
with a red umbrella and what whatever
you give to the system the system will
give you as is an output a little girl
girl with a pink umbrella the under was
read the the word that was detected from
the visual detector was was read and
maybe sometimes it had like other colors
with a very low confidence score but it
was very clear that this was a bias that
was generated from the language model
because the the data that was collected
to train this model was was also biased
but I think it is worth exploring in
seeing how do these ethical issues get
entangled together and or whether we
actually need separate components for
blocking all these issues or whether we
should have one stuffed module in each
component that is make the component
aware of all this
great thank you better okay our final
talk for the session is from Dan BOE
who's dan is actually just celebrating
ten years at Microsoft Research
so congratulations Dan in that time he's
worked on a ton of physically situated
language interactive systems from
directions robots to virtual assistants
and today he's going to be talking about
a new platform to hopefully make that
work and all of our work a lot of time
you guys hear me okay yeah so I guess
I'm standing between you guys and lunch
I'll try to keep this short and sweet I
will not be talking directly about
research today I will be talking about a
platform for enabling research I think
we're at the time where you know over
the last years we've seen a lot of fast
paced advances on core perceptual AI
tasks with deep learning vision speech
language but I think it's still the case
that when you try to put together
multiple AI technologies in construct
systems that actually are deployed in
the world and that act in the real world
it gets challenging it's so expensive
it's time-consuming it's error-prone I
think everyone that has built this
system knows it everyone that hasn't
probably underestimates the problems and
so what I want to talk to you about
today is our effort that I've been
involved with in the last couple of
years on developing a platform that
hopefully makes this whole a little bit
just a little bit easier
and lowers the barrier to entry allowing
more people to sort of tackle these
kinds of problems at the intersection of
different AI technologies now to set it
all in context I'm going to start from
my own personal research interests which
are in physically situated language so
the questions that drive me are how do
we get machines to understand how people
interact with each other in physical
space with language now when you say
language interaction the mind
immediately goes to things like speech
recognition and that's a large part of
it but there's language is much more
than that it's a very sort of fine-tuned
richly coordinated
initiative multimodal process we do a
lot with nonverbal behaviors with gays
with pointing with head nods body pose
all of these play a role it's a simple
example of the kind of problem I look at
consider body we take for a robot to
inject itself in a conversation with
three other people well it needs to know
not only what is being said but who is
saying it who are they saying it to is
this person about to finish talking and
when they're finished are they going to
release the flower who do they expect
that will talk next will someone start
talking in the next 300 milliseconds and
so on now clearly solving these kinds of
problems requires bringing to bear many
different kinds of AI technologies you
have to do head post tracking and speech
recognition and voice activation and
sound sort of localization and integrate
all these things together and that work
is hard over the years we build a
variety of systems in this space from
things like avatars that try to look
through cameras and interact with people
in the multi-party turn-taking in the
open world to human robot interaction
scenario like Shawn mentioned we have
the direction giving robots that try to
synchronize pointing with speech as they
interact with people and give directions
inside the building most recently we
started looking at what does the mobile
dimension add into this equation what if
you have a mobile robot how can you make
that more social as it traverses the
environment so we're looking at a number
of questions in that area more recently
I'm going to put a shameless plug in
here for a demo we have of this little
guy it's still early days but we have it
in the other room roaming around go have
a look so that's that's the latest
platform that we're working on but
really I'm not here to talk about these
guys I think the argument I'm making is
that whether you're in this space of
multi modal kind of situated language or
in fact in any domain that brings
together many different technologies
especially if you're dealing with
sensory data and with low latency timing
constraints it's challenging and so what
we set up the challenge is you know in a
large to a large degree stem just from
the complexity of this system
you know they have many different
components integrated in them but I
would argue that it's more than just
complexity we are missing a bunch of
fundamental primitives I think in our
programming languages it still surprises
me that time the very notion of time is
not baked in in our programming
languages same with uncertainty so every
time we go and construct the systems we
kind of have to go back and reinvent the
wheel and being in research usually we
don't do a spectacularly good job of it
now building the systems is not even
half the story I mean maybe a quarter of
the story I think three-quarters of the
story has to do with debugging and
understanding why they don't work
because they won't work and so trying to
debug these kind of complex pipelines
where everything happens is
synchronously for anyone that has done
it they know how painful it can be and
again it's a lack of tools I think that
that we have in this space and then to
put the cherry on top of everything
that's already talked about machine
learning a lot of the components in the
systems are machine learn and they
interact with each other's and errors
propagate in funny ways and and so on
and so driven by basically our
experience and lessons we've learned
over the year this systems and from
experience other people now group have
from robotics we've said to ourselves so
why don't we take a stab at this and try
to construct a platform that will
simplify at least some of these tasks
and enable other people to do research
faster and so we're building this
platform platform for situated
intelligence we're referring to it as I
4 psi but basically there's three three
big components to this framework that
brought together kind of provide the
value and an enable faster development
and research the first part is a set of
basic primitives in a programming model
for parallel coordinated computation
that we refer to as the runtime secondly
there's a set of tools that are heavily
focused on visualization debugging and
enabling a very fast machine learning
group that allows people to sort of
develop their models and inject them
into running systems and thirdly we're
constructing stories you want of AI
technologies a repository of AI
technologies that came
I can play relatively easily with each
other and that hopefully help developers
stay at the high level and and and push
the boundaries from there on so what I
want to do briefly in the remaining time
is just give you guys a couple of
highlights in each of these areas and
yep so I'll start with the run time the
run time as I said provides a set of
basic primitives and a programming model
for parallel coordinated computation how
do we how do we write applications well
I go back to the question to the problem
that I've put before of how does robot
inject itself in this conversation first
problem we has to solve is knowing who
is talking and clearly that's a
multi-modal problem you need to connect
multiple components using the sigh
runtime basically you just get to
connect components to each other it's
what you would think of it you know you
have a camera a face tracker microphone
or a sound source localizing and you
bring them together nothing special so
far and these components communicate
with streams that pass messages to each
other right so it's sort of a very
normal kind of graph architecture what
makes the streaming infrastructure
inside interesting though in contrast to
other streaming infrastructures is that
the strings are time aware so the moment
a message is created when we encounter
it in the world the moment the time
frame the frame is acquired by the video
camera we timestamp it and it travels
through the component chain the the
runtime is aware of the latency and the
components are aware of the latency by
virtue of that so this helps solves a
couple of problems one problem that
often you run into the system is
synchronization the message that came to
the camera for face tracking maybe took
430 milliseconds to get here whereas
this other guy is just 110 millisecond
delayed with respect to the world and so
we're providing a time algebra and the
right synchronization primitives so that
the developers of the systems don't have
to think through all of that and solve
that problem we're managing a lot of
that automatically the second aspect
that this time awareness kind of enables
is a very performant type of scheduling
so the component in the system is all
executing parallel not synchronously
they're isolated from each other and we
maintain isolation but we have a
scheduler
that because it's aware of all the time
and all the latencies can retain really
good scaler properties like if I give
you more computational power this thing
will leverage it and will use it but if
the computation power for whatever
reason goes down if there's pressure on
it you will it will be great gracefully
and so there's all this work that we've
done in the lower level to make this
sure that these systems run smooth and
like butter and you know the scheduling
is done properly
finally the last bit I want to say about
the runtime is that all the data that
travels through these streams can be
automatically persisted no matter what
type it is so you get a uniform logging
infrastructure where you don't have to
worry about logging in your application
everything can be persisted and this is
fundamental when you do work with
machine learning data driven models it's
another step that we're removing sort of
from the friction that a developer
typically encounters and with the data
I'll switch gears and talk a little bit
about the tools as I said the tools are
geared a lot on debugging and
visualization and machine learning
visualization is fundamental what I have
here is a video running of someone
interacting with the visualization
environment that that we have but
basically anytime you want to debug your
systems because of the complexity of the
things involved you really need you you
cannot set breakpoints you really need
to go and visualize and be able to see
your data you can inspect all the
strings that your application has and
construct different kinds of
visualization the visualizes are
composable you can overlay you know
that's a visualizer for a stream of
images overlaid with the visualizer for
faces we have an audio signal here
overlay with a voice activity detector
and then with speech recognition results
all the way to basically constructing
more interesting kind of visualizes
visuals latency of messages like of
partial results from the recognizer
where the message was generated here but
by the time the results came back to the
cloud I was actually here all the way to
3d understanding of basically the scene
that the system assembles as it
interacts with people and so we put a
fair amount of effort into this and it
continues or further developing this
visualization tools as they they play a
fundamental role the visualizer system
is set up distributed you can run live
so you have an application running live
somewhere you can connect to it
can see what's going on in a life
writing application not only on offline
data and so on you can navigate through
it all what you would expect another
really important capability and this is
again because of the runtime persistence
or all the timing information is that
you can replay these data and experiment
so once i've captured a session my
camera and microphone i can just start
replaying the same data and we have
because time is under control with
virtualized time we have the capability
to run let's say replay just at the
speed that the camera was going like it
was happening in the real world or go as
fast as you can as long as no one else
down the pipe eye drops and things like
that so there's a there's a lot of
infrastructure allowing people to
experiment over data and tune a
component and then look how would that
have looked like and that again helps
with this entire debugging and
maintenance and experimentation process
and finally we are putting a lot of
effort into streamlining machine
learning we're not into developing new
machine learning algorithms we leave
that to other people but what we're
looking at is creating a very fast loop
because oftentimes the work in machine
learning ends up being about writing
Python scripts or Perl scripts to
process some data and move it from one
environment to another we're trying to
keep something that that's very tight
and I get you all the way really quickly
to integrating and running the model
back into your system so that more
models actually see the life of day in
real time applications don't just sit
somewhere in MATLAB scripts and so we're
developing on that front as well the
third bit has been a talk briefly about
is the set of components and here it's
what you would imagine were wrapping a
lot of existing technologies from
sensing technologies to vision speech
you know various kinds of human
perception technology there's a long
laundry list we're also being careful to
a bridge and interrupts with other
existing echo systems we have for
instance bridges to Ross for people that
are doing robotics bridges to OpenCV and
more constructing more such integrations
or bridging to other existing ecosystems
we want everything to kind of play
nicely and sort of enable more research
the final bid I'll say here is that
separately given my personal interested
in language and this kind of physically
situated interactions were
building a toolkit which you can think
of it as a self I components that are
geared towards enabling or constructing
this kind of language interactive
systems that reason sort of about
higher-level constructs like identity
attention interrupt ability and all
these things that you need to reason
about when you're interacting with
people in the world so I think I'm going
to close on this I will we are this is a
platform that we're planning to release
and so we're inviting collaboration get
in touch with us if you think you might
be interested I also say there is a we
will run a small kind of we can go in
more details with questions and all the
way to the code will run a short
tutorial at 1:15 and at 2:15 in the last
one room in parallel it set up in
parallel with a technology showcase with
the demos but we're doing two
consecutive sessions when starting a
1:15 1 or 2:15 so you can attend any of
those and then see that see the demo
still in the in the other part but
hopefully this is something that people
will find useful we certainly know it's
kind of simplified our own lives and
I'll stop here and take questions
[Applause]
so thanks this looks super useful to me
and one of the common kinds of problems
into working with real-time systems is
when you have a component that's making
a decision and it is but it's making the
decision based on kind of stale
information so you have a downstream
component like a generator that's
generating something in real time and
you're kind of looking at it and saying
ok something went wrong I'm not quite
sure what went wrong and go look at your
module it looks like it's working
correctly but it if you really drill in
you figure out that the information that
it needed to have to make the correct
decision was in the pipeline but it
hadn't reached the module yet not sort
of thing so I'm wondering like do you
have support for kind of navigating and
kind of what was the information that
was available at the moment this
was made yes so we're building exactly
sorry I'm very familiar with the kind of
problem here that yeah completely
sympathize yes so a lot of the runtime
is around this time algebra that
basically provides you visibility first
of all into that then on top of that
were constructing the right kind of
visualization tools now the
visualization tools I showed you here
mostly lets you look at the data at the
same time we have other kinds of tools
that let you dump or pipeline as a graph
and see basically the messages that were
received when so you can you you kind of
have full visibility because everything
is time-stamped now of course I think
there's more there's more kind of tools
that we need to build or layers in here
you know to allow you to kind of fastly
narrow down on something and not have to
search for it but in the long run I mean
I'm really envisioning this as sort of
if you're almost like integrated as a
development environment like with Visual
Studio okay maybe activate historical
debugging based on something and go back
in time and see what exactly happened at
that point and those are the problems
were trying to solve thank you so
presumably it I mean you've got a
dataflow system here and presumably
there's ways that I can set up a barrier
or I can actually wait for things that
yes okay secondly it seems have you
developed a way to encapsulate existing
bits of code that can plug into this
runtime yeah so no so the the what we're
doing right now actually for the
component development is were shrink
wrapping a lot of existing technologies
and the wrapping of the technologies
into this fabric is actually pretty
straightforward and to the point where
we're thinking you know for certain
kinds of classes of problems we might be
able to do it automatically but the
wrapping is mostly consisting of hey say
you have a parser takes in a string
gives in a parse tree I mostly have to
shrink wrap a component that says now
I'm going to take a stream of string and
I'm going to put out a stream of parse
tree where stream is a primitive from
our library so we we do the effort to
shrink wrapping things is relatively
lightweight and yet the hope is that we
can take a lot of existing technologies
in kind of partition to get them to
participate in this ecosystem there's
one question here one line right at the
front right here on the front right here
in the front
oh yeah it looks like a very useful
system
you mentioned the bridge to Ross and
OpenCV I think these are very important
practically how to to what extent is the
action can they be accommodated into the
system like like in a way you like you
mentioned the shrink-wrap or so that you
can use all these Ross cooperating inner
inner like a modules then you can keep
track of the timing timestream sir
so what we're actually doing with Ross
for is it's an actual bridge so it's a
real bridge so you can have an entire
Ross system running streaming to another
size system and the to communicate with
each other actually the demo of the
robot that I showed the mobile robot
show there's going to be demonstrated
the way it's implemented is got I think
a Ross system running for the some of
the navigation bits that runs on a Linux
machine coupled with a bunch of Windows
Phi components running the system for
interaction and for you know interacting
with people so
that my question is that when you talk
about a componentize the system maker
you think about it like the different
component needs to tolerate the errors
from from each other when they're
communicating with each other I was
wondering is there any thinking like
when you put all these pieces together
is there a way you can do some
end-to-end optimisation sort of thing to
to make it perform really in the best
absolutely absolutely so I think the the
the time awareness you know provides
part of the key here so I'll form
answers into two different bits that I
will say one with respect because we
have time awareness you could imagine
and we've actually work out through
examples where I can run an online
learning algorithms algorithm that Tunes
the parameter on one of the component to
obey some constraint later in the
pipeline I want to say latency five
components after my face tracker I want
it to be around 600 milliseconds but no
longer and I can I have all the
information I need to learn online
basically how to do and we're planning
with the runtime to evolve it in those
directions now there's also you know
when we say errors there's errors that
have to do with time and with messages
that get dropped and that's where the
runtime has a lot of visibility and then
there's errors that are semantic like
for instance this particle components
said the wrong thing those we have less
visibility into you know but we're still
hoping to provide a bunch of you know
information and tools for people to
build models to address those challenges
I think I think what's important is this
unified kind of fabric unified
infrastructure that would allow us to
study you know the kinds of problems
that besides talking about not in a
one-by-one fashion but rather when I
have 15 systems implemented on this
platform because at the bottom it's all
unified I can look in a systemic way
like you know what are the
characteristics and I can try to learn
system something across many different
systems as opposed to kind of in this
piecewise fashion you're opening line
which is exactly right that it's it's
unbelievable but true that time is not
fundamental primitive to those of these
things those of us who've worked in labs
were time happy one of the reasons
people embraced Ross was at least even
if you aren't using robots you could
connect this stuff together
from a research community perspective it
would be great for some sense for this
to a label some research thinking deeply
about how time is best represented for
these kinds of systems time stamps we
understand a reasonable amount in being
able to buffer them so you can get to
them and it's great that it's going to
support that there's this question of
course of intervals and and how that and
you know by you creating a system like
this it allow folks to experiment with
exactly that so the more you can trying
to advocate for you exposing as much of
that as possible so we can play with
that because I'm going to guess that
pretty soon people will run into
limitations on any particular time model
that you embed in time stamps or
otherwise and man that is it is so
critical to us building systems that
actually engage out there so you know
the more you expose that the happier
we're all going to be for that good yes
that is that is exactly the goal the
goal is to I want us to I mean ideally
in the long run I want to get to almost
like a understanding more deeply a
science of how do we do integration and
time is a big part of it and you know
the other big part in that equation
where I hope to that that frameworks
like this will help us sort of study is
uncertainty because uncertainty
propagation in the systems and dealing
with our certainty is another thing that
that has the same kind of challenges
around it okay I think it's about time
for lunch thank you get there with that
perfect y'all peace thank you all for
coming